even though one piece is filled with
thrilling battles and exciting action
sequences between strong characters some
of the fights we are most excited about
we never actually get to see but what
actually makes the off-screen fights in
one place so intriguing and how can they
create so much hype in the community
fighting is an essential part of the
Wampus manga since despite of its vast
world and complex storyline at the base
of it all it is still a shounen manga
and fights are the main reason many of
us get into one piece in the first place
baddest characters would devil free
powers ranging from fantastic to
straight-up weird as well as the
introduction of additional power to use
such as hockey and awakenings have not
only kept the action alive but much
rather develop it further and made it
even more capturing only as the story
progressed further and further and also
the readers slowly grew older did wampie
start to fascinate with more mature
stylistic elements such as politics or
emotional and moral conflicts but it
also allowed Oda to increasingly make
use of a very different type of battle
off screen fights what I'm talking about
here are epic battles and duels that we
never actually get to see but are only
hinted at by characters in the story
these kind of fights evolved to become
an essential part of Oda's world
building by having a significant impact
on the story of one piece
these showdowns shape the flow of events
and therefore also the path Luffy and
his crew take on their journey to raftel
while some of these fights are not shown
to us simply to not disturb the flow of
the storyline they are often also
deliberately used by Oda as a tool to
create hype and suspense but how exactly
does he manage to do that so well and
why do we love these fights so much off
screen fights work so well as a
stylistic element in the one-piece story
because they fulfill a handful of
purposes at the same time that only get
clearer once you take a moment to really
think about them let's start with some
of the more obvious ones
first of all off screen fights allow for
Oda to integrate epic clashes into the
story without having to actually show
them now this might seem obvious at
first glance since it is literally the
definition of off screen but how
powerful this really is becomes clear
when you look at how popular these kinds
of fights actually are after all some of
them have
a lot more attention than fights we
actually got to witness to achieve this
Oda first gives us a glimpse at
characters powers to let us get an idea
of what they are truly capable of next
he puts this character against someone
who's also perceived as strong or
mysterious he then uses this piece of
information to put a certain expectation
into its readers head all he now has to
do is to announce that this clash took
place at some point somewhere in the
world and let the reader's imagination
do the rest of the work for him we are
actually the ones who really make these
unseen battles as great as they are
simply because ode allows them to happen
as we want to imagine them in our minds
by not showing them to us at all a great
example of this is the fight between
garb sangoku and shiki we will only fete
little bits of how powerful these three
characters must have been in the prime
of the days only to learn later on that
the three actually fought each other now
we do not have any idea how this fight
really went down it is possible that
Garvin sangoku simply hit Shiki over the
head after 10 seconds and the whole
thing was over in an instant but with
the information Oda gave us what we all
have in our minds is an epic fight on
the highest level with all three of them
going all-out with the devil fruits in
hockey this allows odour to save himself
the trouble of illustrating such a fight
without making it any less capturing and
this also directly leads into my second
purpose which is building expectations
for later fights in the story when
hearing of the power of certain
characters and whom they fought in the
past we can wait to actually see them in
action in the future next to the yonk oh
one of the most prominent examples for
this is probably the clash between the
two admirals alkie G and a canoe on Punk
hazard we first hear about their battle
from Jim Bay and Fishman Islands who
lets us in on the background of the
fight namely control over the Marines
Jim Bay then tells Luffy that the fight
lasted an incredible 10 days and that
even though both were more less equal in
strength in the end Aquino defeated out
key G later on when the straw has
actually arrived at punk hazard we can
see the consequences of that fight the
islands entire climate and weather had
been changed completely by the battle
turning it into half icy desert half
Mordor with the knowledge that to awaken
loga uses
here we can't help but yearn for the day
we finally get to see a kind whanau qiji
go full out with their powers this
example also connects to the third
purpose of off-screen fights namely the
driving of unexpected game-changing
events the fight between these two
admirals determine the entire structure
of the Marines one of the most powerful
and influential entities in the Wampus
world this unseen fight was the source
of the heart cores taken up by the
Marines after the war that once again
introduced them as a worthy opponent
even when entering the new world another
great example for this is obviously
Sheng stopping Kaito from getting
involved into the war of the greatest
which would most likely have changed the
outcome of it completely another one
that comes to mind is the continuation
of the fight between Blackbeard and ace
that finally led to aces defeat and
therefore to the start of the war itself
all this was made possible by fights
that we never actually got to see more
than a glimpse off and this brings me to
the fourth and last purpose of
off-screen fights in one piece which is
at least as important as all the others
Pawel scaling power scaling is something
very popular and Shonen manga and is
often introduced in the story itself
most prominently seen in Dragon Ball
while undoubtedly the fights we actually
see in the story function as a way of
power scaling too they are often
tailored to destroy it crew also
considering the sometimes rather unusual
circumstances when it comes to fights of
the crew a real comparison between
characters is kind of difficult it's for
example NRO weaker than the Flamingo
just because luffy needed two years of
training and gear forth to defeat the
one but not the other
not necessarily in my opinion luffy
being made of rubber simply gave him an
advantage in these special circumstances
as a result many of the fights often
don't really offer us a very clear
picture of a character's strength in
relation to the entirety of the world
peace world offspring fights on the
other hand simply state the outcome of a
fight between two characters well this
doesn't mean that special circumstances
cannot occur here as well it is usually
employed by Oda that it was a head-on
clash power was his power we expect GARP
to be a strong character since he was
able to take on the likes of cheeky and
Roger we expect Blackbeard to be
incredibly
strong for seemingly effortlessly being
able to defeat the revolutionaries and
bout to go as well as the white beer
pirates in the payback war additionally
he also seems to have clashed with
shanks before and was seen as a threat
by him from very early on in the story
apart from the short claims of the fight
with ace we do not have any idea of what
Blackbeard is truly capable of yet we
still have a very good idea in which
leaky place mostly through those battles
that we have never actually seen so we
have now seen that off-screen fights in
one piece serve for different purposes
integrating battles without having to
actually show them building expectations
for future fights allowing for
unexpected events to influence the flow
of the story and functioning as a tool
for power scaling characters we haven't
seen in full action yet while these
purposes alone show us why off-screen
fights are so relevant for the story we
still haven't fully explored why they
fascinate us so much so what actually
makes them so intriguing again from my
perspective there are four main reasons
for the power of this storytelling
method the first one is basically the
combination of the previous points the
power scaling of off-screen fights
combined with the increasing knowledge
of the Wampus world and the anticipation
of seeing those characters in action can
be summarized as a tool of character
construction the most relevant example
for this at the moment might be Kaido
knowing how he decimated gaku Moria as
well as Kit apoo and basil Hawkins even
before coming to on oh we had a very
good idea of what Cato might be capable
of doing and what level he was operating
on this character construction is now
slowly filled with details as we get to
know more and more about Qaeda's powers
and character traits which all-in-all
allows for a more complete character
design
the second reason off-screen fights are
so intriguing is the one piece community
itself no matter if its youtube channel
forums podcasts or conventions the
community surrounding the story is
filled with an overflowing amount of
discussions theories reviews and
analysis the enthusiasm and imagination
of the fans is a central driver of the
story thus mysteries and unseen events
are always a highly relevant topic in
the community and off stream fights are
probably one of them
discussed fields and all of these
platforms thus the Wampus community or
namely you guys are what really makes
these fights so special and what makes
them so much fun to think and talk about
next is odours love for plot twists and
I think I will not have to explain this
to you too much in detail since you are
all more than familiar with them Oda
simply loves to play with his Rita's
expectations and the off-screen fights
are no exception the possibility that an
event took place completely differently
than we originally thought is what makes
it so intriguing to talk and discuss
about an example here would be the
general believe that garb defeated Roger
and captured him in the end only after a
long time we actually learned that Roger
turned himself in being lethally sick
anyway twists like that drive our
imagination to come up with the most
fantastic theories about unseen fights
and events and even if these turn out to
be wrong just coming up with theories
and being proven wrong is what many
people including me enjoy so much about
one piece last but not least the fourth
reason that makes off-screen fights in
one piece so intriguing is the mystery
they create not really knowing how
fights went down and what powers were
used drives us mad with curiosity how
are the black bear pirates able to win
the payback war so easily what is the
secret to their power
what makes Qaeda and Big Mama into such
indestructible beings and how will Luffy
be able to rise to the level in the end
it is those mysteries surrounding strong
characters powers and traits that we
haven't seen yet that are essential part
of the story success now to illustrate
these four points let's look at the most
prominent example for off-screen fights
and that is shanks he's one of the most
hyped and intriguing characters in the
story for a reason he incorporates all
the factors we have explored just now to
better understand this let's take a look
at the off-screen fights we know if that
shanks had so far all of them are means
of character construction for shanks in
terms of power scaling anticipation and
twists all of them are shrouded a
mystery and all of them have been
discussed by the community so often and
so throughout that it actually might be
difficult for order to come up with a
storyline that has been speculated yet
shanks stopped Kaido on his way to
marine for
but did they actually fight and if yes
how strong is shanks to come out of this
whole thing unscathed and it changed
really fly Blackbeard and again if yes
did this make Blackbeard stronger than
kaido's several years ago since he was
actually able to hurt shanks also shanks
is known to have had a rivalry with me
hawk who is said to have been able to
compete on his level
did shanks fight with all his might
there and if yes how strong does that
make me hawk in comparison all of these
events make the community twitch with
excitement every time we see shanks - as
much as sit on a rock reading a
newspaper all in all this shows just how
powerful and relevant off-screen fights
are for the storytelling of Oda and how
it has contributed a significant part to
accessorize of let's look at the most
recent major off-screen fight we got in
the story the Revolutionary Army versus
the two Admirals fujitora and Greenville
not only will it significantly hype up
which ever slide wins and will also have
a critical impact on the story
additionally it is the central set up
for the return of the reverie arc in
2019 that has been announced recently by
Oda I hope I was able to lay out the
importance of off-screen fights in one
piece to you guys and show you which
purpose they serve and which factors
make them so intriguing and hype now I
have a question for you guys do you
think there should be flashbacks to
off-screen fights in one piece and why
or why not share your thoughts on this
in the comments below and also feel free
of course to share your opinion on any
other aspect of this video if you liked
this video please make sure to like
share and subscribe to be notified for
any future content of mine at this point
I also want to thank manage guard for
choosing this topic in the 100
subscriber contest as well as everyone
else who participated
I will definitely also tackle some of
the other topics that were proposed in
the future now all that's left to do is
wish you guys a great start into the new
year and I'm looking forward to seeing
where we can take this channel in 2019
together and as always guys have a great
week
[Music]
you
[Music]